parce que c'est ridicule.
Nous savons que les informations sur le changement climatique
sont étouffées pour plein de raisons.
Je l'ai vu de près quand j'étais professeur d'université.
On l'a vu quand des pays se sont retirés des accords mondiaux sur le climat
tels le protocole de Kyoto et l'accord de Paris,
et on le voit encore quand l'industrie n'arrive pas à tenir ses engagements
de réduction d'émission de gaz à effet de serre.
Mais il n'y a pas que l'information sur le changement climatique
qui est étouffée.
Tant de questions scientifiques sont brouillées par les faits alternatifs,
les fake news et autres formes de manipulation de l'information.
On l'a vu au Royaume-Uni,
on l'a vu en Russie,
on l'a vu aux États-Unis
et, jusqu'en 2015,
ici même au Canada.
En cette époque technologique,
au moment où notre survie même dépend de la recherche,
de l'innovation et de la science,
il est crucial, absolument crucial,
que nos scientifiques soient libres de travailler,
libres de collaborer avec d'autres scientifiques,
libres de parler aux media
et libres de parler au grand public.
Parce qu'après tout,
la science est ce que l'humanité a de mieux pour découvrir la vérité
sur notre monde,
sur notre existence même.
Chaque nouvelle découverte
s'ajoute à la masse croissante de nos connaissances collectives.
Les scientifiques doivent être libres d'explorer
des sujets non conventionnels, voire controversés.
Ils doivent être libres de remettre en cause notre manière de penser actuelle
et ils doivent être libres
de présenter des vérités inconfortables ou dérangeantes,
car c'est ainsi que les scientifiques repoussent les limites.
Et les repousser, c'est, après tout, ce à quoi sert la science.
Et enfin,
les scientifiques doivent être libres de se tromper,
car même une hypothèse fausse nous apprend quelque chose.
La meilleure manière de l'expliquer est de raconter une de mes propres aventures.
Mais je dois d'abord vous faire remonter le temps.
Au début du XXe siècle,
Claire et Vera étaient colocataires dans le sud de l'Ontario.
Un soir, au plus fort de l'épidémie de grippe espagnole,
elles ont assisté à un cours ensemble.
A la fin de la soirée, elles sont rentrées à la maison et se sont couchées.
Le matin, Claire a appelé Vera
pour lui dire qu'elle sortait petit-déjeuner.
Quand elle est revenue un peu plus tard,
Vera ne s'était pas levée.
Elle a soulevé les couvertures
et a fait une horrible découverte.
Vera était morte.
Quand on parle de grippe espagnole,
ce type d'histoire est courant,
la mort survenait très rapidement.
La première fois que j'ai entendu ces faits choquants,
j'étais professeur et j'avais entre 20 et 30 ans,
et la scientifique en moi a voulu savoir pourquoi et comment.
Ma curiosité m'a menée dans des contrées gelées
à la tête d'une expédition,
voulant découvrir les causes de la grippe espagnole de 1918.
Je voulais tester nos médicaments modernes
sur l'une des maladies les plus mortelles de l'histoire.
J'espérais qu'on créerait un vaccin
qui serait efficace contre le virus
et toutes ses mutations,
si jamais il devait réapparaître.
J'ai dirigé donc une équipe de recherche
de 17 hommes,
venus du Canada, de Norvège, du Royaume-Uni
et des États-Unis,
dans l'archipel du Svalbard, dans l'océan Arctique.
Ces îles se trouvent entre la Norvège et le pôle Nord.
On a exhumé six corps
morts à cause de la grippe espagnole et enterrés dans le permafrost.
Nous espérions que le sol gelé aurait préservé les corps et le virus.
Je sais ce que vous attendez tous,
le super retour sur investissement scientifique.
Mais mon histoire n'a pas de dénouement heureux comme dans les films.
La plupart n'en ont pas.
La réalité est que nous n'avons pas trouvé le virus,
mais nous avons développé de nouvelles techniques
pour exhumer en toute sécurité des corps
qui pourraient contenir un virus.
Nous avons développé de nouvelles techniques
pour prélever en toute sécurité des tissus
qui pourraient contenir un virus.
Et nous avons développé de nouveaux protocoles de sécurité
pour protéger l'équipe de recherche et les gens autour.
Nous avons grandement contribué à la science,
même si nos contributions
n'étaient pas celles prévues initialement.
En science, des tentatives échouent,
des résultats sont peu concluants
et des théories ne donnent pas les résultats escomptés.
En science,
la recherche se construit à partir du travail et de la recherche des autres
ou en regardant plus loin,
en nous tenant sur les épaules des géants,
pour paraphraser Newton.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que les scientifiques doivent être libres
de choisir ce qu'ils veulent explorer,
ce par quoi ils sont passionnés
et ils doivent être libres de publier leurs découvertes.
J'ai dit tout à l'heure
que le respect envers la science a commencé à s'améliorer au Canada en 2015.
Comment avons-nous fait ?
Quelles leçons pouvons-nous partager ?
Eh bien, cela remonte à l'époque où j'étais professeur.
J'ai observé comment les agences,
les gouvernements et les industries du monde entier
ont étouffé l'information sur le changement climatique.
Cela m'a mise en fureur.
Cela m'a empêchée de dormir.
Comment les politiciens pouvaient-ils tordre les faits scientifiques
à des fins partisanes ?
J'ai fait ce que quiconque de consterné par la politique aurait fait :
je me suis présentée aux élections et j'ai été élue.
(Applaudissements)
Je voulais utiliser cette nouvelle plateforme
pour évoquer l'importance de la science.
C'est rapidement devenu une bataille pour la liberté de la science.
Après tout, j'étais une scientifique, venant d'un monde qui était attaqué
et j'avais personnellement ressenti cette indignation.
Je pouvais être la voix de ceux qu'on réduisait au silence.
Mais j'ai vite compris que les scientifiques étaient nerveux,
même inquiets à l'idée de me parler.
Un scientifique travaillant pour le gouvernement, un ami --
appelons-le McPherson --
avait des inquiétudes quant à l'impact
que les politiques gouvernementales avaient sur ses recherches
et quant à la détérioration de l'état de la science au Canada.
Il était si inquiet qu'il m'a écrit
en utilisant l'adresse e-mail de sa femme
parce qu'il avait peur qu'un appel téléphonique soit tracé.
Il voulait que je l'appelle sur le numéro de sa femme,
pour que son appel ne soit pas tracé.
J'aimerais que ce soit une blague.
Cela m'a rapidement fait comprendre ce qu'il se passait au Canada.
Combien un ami de 20 ans pouvait être aussi effrayé de me parler ?
J'ai donc fait ce que je pouvais faire à l'époque.
Je l'ai écouté et j'ai partagé ce que j'avais appris
avec mon ami au parlement,
un homme qui s'intéressait à tout : l'environnement, la science,
la technologie, l'innovation.
Puis, en 2015, les élections ont eu lieu
et notre parti a gagné.
Nous avons formé un gouvernement.
Et cet ami au parlement
est désormais Premier ministre -- c'est Justin Trudeau.
(Applaudissements)
Et il m'a demandé si je voulais devenir son ministre des Sciences.
Ensemble, avec tout le gouvernement,
nous travaillons dur pour redonner sa juste place à la science.
Je n'oublierai jamais ce jour de décembre 2015,
où j'ai parlé devant le parlement
et proclamé :
« La guerre contre la science est terminée ».
(Applaudissements)
Et j'ai travaillé dur pour que ces paroles soient suivies d'actes.
Nous avons connu de nombreuses réussites.
Il y a encore tant de travail,
nous construisons ce changement de mentalité.
Nous voulons que nos scientifiques parlent avec les media, avec le public.
Ça prendra du temps, mais nous sommes déterminés.
Après tout, le Canada est perçu comme un phare pour la science
dans le monde entier.
Nous voulons envoyer le message
qu'il ne faut pas interférer avec quelque chose d'aussi fondamental,
d'aussi précieux que la science.
Donc, pour le Dr Bothwell, pour Claire et Vera,
pour McPherson et tous les autres,
si vous voyez que la science est muselée, étouffée ou attaquée,
faites-le savoir.
Si vous voyez que des scientifiques sont réduits au silence, faites-le savoir.
Nous devons tenir nos leaders pour responsables.
Que ce soit en exerçant notre droit de vote,
en signant une tribune dans un journal
ou en lançant une conversation sur les réseaux sociaux,
seule notre voix collective garantira la liberté de la science.
Et après tout, la science appartient à tous,
elle nous mènera tous vers un avenir meilleur, plus éclatant, plus audacieux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)